O2 mugclub forever.com enter in your
email you can bring that up on full
screen toolman uh just so you nope just
so you know this is a horrible start uh
muglovforever.com look yesterday and the
day before when we put this up the
servers crashed we had DDOS attacks I
want to make sure that you know it now
100 works if you signed up before you're
hearing this right now I ask that you
sign up again the email list may not
actually work because of what happened
with the servers uh so some
announcements that we have to make
um
I mug Club am leaving The Blaze this is
a long time coming
um obviously and I had been hoping that
this would be of course a joint
statement
um I've lost sleep over this for months
because I knew that I wouldn't be
renewing and of course the blaze knew
that I wouldn't be renewing but I have
no way of reaching you
I'm precluded from being able to reach
you and that's why if you go in and
enter your email so we don't lose touch
with you at mugclub forever.com uh we
can enter that in there and every time I
mention it to a man just bring it up
every time you got good that's why
I'll uh be mentioning it to ad nauseam
here because it's the only way that I
can get in touch with you I don't know
how many of you there I only know that
there are well over 300 000 of you who
have paid to sign up and watch that uh
hundreds of thousands of you watch on
mug Club every day in addition to the 2
million or so uh plays and downloads
individual screens for for each
individual show
I haven't talked about that in the past
that's not including Clips two million
of your screens your phones your devices
every single show and I only know
there's over 300 000 of you out there
so please here's what I ask you is mug
Club finds a new home don't lose touch
with us sign up just enter in your email
there at mudclub forever.com I want to
I'm promising you you will never receive
an email from me aside from if when and
where mug club's new home is going to
exist
with the exception that some of you may
receive an immediate email just to
confirm that you signed up so that it
doesn't go to spam and I ask that you
check your spam because due to issues
outside of my control it's going to take
some time before I figure out exactly
where Mud Club lands so All I Ask really
right now is that if you want Mud Club
to continue enter in your email so we
can make that happen
um
I knew that uh you know our my
partnership which for a long time was
was obviously very happy with lots of
great people there uh my partnership
with the blaze would be ending for a
long time uh they knew they know that
they've known that and it's always
weighed really heavy on my heart for the
people who sign up and don't get your
full Year's worth of content I chose
chats fun
um and I've been really trying
really hoping for a simple resolution
look this should be really easy you
signed up to support and watch this show
I obviously believe the right thing to
do would be to make it easy for you to
follow the show you signed up for and to
continue watching it
I really hope that that's exactly what
transpires
uh with the blaze this again was
supposed to be a joint statement
um considering that you well know
comment below if you remember that this
was always promoted as being my last
show of the year
so that was kind of a deadline right and
now actually we will be broadcasting
next week Monday Tuesday largely uh on
my club we have a Christmas special on
uh on Wednesday where we give back and
donate to families and needs so I don't
have your emails I don't have your sign
ups so as of this moment the only thing
that I can do is tell you to enter in
your email at Mud clubforever.com so
that I don't lose touch with you and of
course you know follow me on social
media rumble's probably the best place
to subscribe uh right now because
YouTube notifications don't necessarily
work but this does bring me to something
important which is not lost on me and
frankly has uh really made me made me so
nervous uh almost to the point of being
sick to my stomach token now and if you
can bring up that chat
um
one of you asked yesterday I literally
just subbed to the blaze last week for
mug Club
are they counting you no uh should I ask
for a refund no I'm not saying that you
should ask for a refund some people have
asked if there will be some kind of a
partial reimbursement or some kind of
abridging
I would hope
that the answer there would be yes
I can't speak for all Partners involved
all I can say is that since it is
somewhat outside of my control whatever
decision is made I will make it right
if that means honoring your time left on
your membership wherever my club may be
if it means I have to take out a
business loan if it means I have to show
up at your house as a telegram in a
stupid outfit which you know I'll do I
will make it right now I know
um that if that's what's required of me
it's going to be very expensive and of
course that would never make sense as it
relates to good business uh I'm sure
everyone understands this I've never
been very good at good business you've
seen the things I've said
and sure look there's everyone needs to
make a living business is important but
mug Club has never been about the altar
of good business it's about you it's
about the viewer it's about the listener
it's about the member and I understand
that you are not a rich Republican donor
I understand that it means a lot to you
to part with your hard-earned dollars
and that is not a responsibility and a
vote of trust that I take lightly
but I can't honor it
if you don't ensure that we don't lose
touch in order to serve you I need you
to just enter your email at mugclub
forever.com follow the rest of my social
media for updates and again because of
issues outside of my control the
the logistical aspect Financial aspect
of doing right by you is going to take
some time now yeah of course look
there's been speculation there's been
plenty of Tire kickers there's been
offers opportunities
whatever and wherever we build next
one thing is for sure I know that I need
to build it correctly
that's going to take some time
this show is genuinely funded by viewers
like you you mug Club not a foreign
caliphate
and that's a real thing some of these
networks out there it is actually funded
not not by federal tax dollars like PBS
it's actually entirely funded by viewers
like you and it's why I have promised
you
and trying to do right right by you with
this show that I would only ever do at
most one sponsorship spot per show
and I will always keep it
and if it gets to the point by the way
where there are not enough of you out
there who want this show who want Mud
Club who want us to even produce and
create more content Waters warm folks
we're becoming a production house love
to hear from you
if we get to the point where there's not
enough of you out there look I will
leave and I will pass that torch there
is nothing worse than seeing someone
whose races run refusing to pass the
mantle that's not that's not what I want
to do but that's not our problem right
now
the truth is there are too many of you
that's our problem to the point that
people in this industry this
conservative in many in many cases
across don't believe it
and to the point that I need to build
something or partner with someone who
can build the house on a foundation that
can handle it again to be clear there
are many great people of course at the
blaze many of them have been on this
show
and I've always aimed for the transition
to be as seamless for you as possible uh
to be as as private as possible I've
exhausted all options avoided any kind
of public discussion at all costs for as
long as I could and I was hoping for a
jointly release statement before my
final broadcast which comment below
everyone well knew was today
because of the crash of the servers
we'll be broadcasting next week doing
episodes of you can't say that on
YouTube which should be a lot of fun to
end out the year and we'll be doing the
Crowder gives back I get to dress up as
Santa Claus and give to families in need
and Charities uh but today was supposed
to be the last show now at this point
I'm still hoping for a transition of all
of you mug Club subscribers
seamlessly and that everyone involved in
this partnership places uh places of
trust into the viewers you paying with
your hard-earned dollars that with the
same trust you've placed in me you've
placed in us to fight big Tech and
genuinely to try and win back the soul
of our country despite the wiener jokes
so I do hope for your support uh I hope
for support across the board with all of
this undertaking but if required I will
undertake the burden
for all of it
and doing right by you and making sure
that none of you feel as though you
haven't gotten what you've paid for what
you have built is too important
to everyone right now watching
listening downloading
to the point that this industry doesn't
believe you exist
to the point that the venues don't
believe that you will fill them
it's one of those things it honestly has
been an incredible ride and really
gosh The Best Is Yet To Come we just
have to be ready to handle it you have
my word that I want to place the trust
in you that you have placed in us we are
not betting on I'm not betting on me I'm
betting on you
you have my word go to mugclub
forever.com enter in your email again
you will receive no emails no spam no
selling of your list aside from one
email regarding when where and if mug
Club returns and how it will make it
right for you depending on when you
signed up and if there's more content to
which you are entitled
um
I want to remove all doubt
or any trepidation that uh
your trust in everyone here everyone
here at lotto's Crowder uh was was
misplaced in any way we always have your
back I can't tell you how much it means
throughout these years that you have had
my back uh and uh outside of that you
will all probably receive one video
update not receive you can check YouTube
you can check uh you can check Rumble
Instagram all those places there will be
one video update from me in early
January as I understand logistically uh
what we'll be doing and how we'll be
building this so an update in January
early mid-January stay tuned for that
until then
let's all get ready
let's all do the right thing
fill your hands
fight like hell
mugclub forever.com let's go watch Same
Old Lang Syne
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on a snowy Christmasy
[Music]
I didn't recognize the face of first
but then my eyes flew open wide
you went to hug me and the clouds
dispersed my old girlfriend was now a
guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
surgery
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
side
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Dave and I were just professing our
undying love I was like hey man yeah I
love you you know it's just a stressful
time he's like I know I get it and I
just made a Seinfeld joke I said oh I'm
stressed he's like no no I'm like shut
up
don't talk about the hammock no all
right Secret we have so much uh to get
to here today obviously and uh please
look Duke this is probably the most
important done that I ask this of you
comment like hit the rumble button share
everything you can just please do not
let us lose touch with you mugclub
forever.com
no spam I know what you're thinking man
maybe some spam no none of that no
you're gonna see about it that's in my
head because I listened to my mom argue
with Alexa this morning Alexa close the
light turning up the lights no I say
close the lightest
because in French it translates to fail
I'm close okay hold on before okay we're
gonna be talking about a lot today all
right I don't know if you know this that
the NHL believes that non-binary
identity is real it's out there
and we have a former female Twitter
employees I don't know I think that's
the is that the X-Files theme I have no
idea I have no idea I was in a film with
David Duchovny were you really he hated
the movie Crash I know that well I did
too yeah I know but I didn't really care
what he thought it's like a mundane
detail yes this crash had come out and I
was working on the film this movie was
terrible they should have it's like oh
okay I guess it's a good thing you
weren't cast yeah I should have got that
part I should have got I still want to
believe it's good yeah that's sour
grapes uh so we have the NHL we have a
former female Twitter employees that are
now suing Elon Musk so that's going to
be fun I don't know if you know this New
York city has an arson problem no and
they have a Hamburglar a real one a real
one wow it's doubly bad it's really it's
a mick doubly bad it's a double Mac Band
no it's not a double Mac thing it's a
quarter pounder with bad hey you know
what comment below has it ever been a
thing in the states a Big Mac with four
patties no in Canada that's what I used
to get in Canada when I was trying to
gain weight you know Judo when I was
young there was a double Big Mac it was
and I would go in to the states and I'd
say give me a double Big Mac like so you
want like one of them to have two
patties and I'm like no I want double on
both there's two patties double would be
four like I don't know when she had like
a heart attack I'm like that's what we
did for years yes where do you put the
middle bread
I mean at that point it's pretty much
just smooshed oh I guess we we had him
here I do remember do we have I do
remember in 2020 yeah oh there it is oh
there's still only one middle brand I
thank you from the bottom of my clogged
Pfizer enlarged heart I'm just kidding
I'm I'm a pure blood I can't believe I'm
the one in the room that didn't know
that existed also Oreos are different
hey I don't know if you know this Pelosi
and Schumer also by the way claim that
uh the low birth rates we have mean that
we mean we need more immigrants now
here's the thing when people use the
term white replacement Theory right
that's a racist of white is the problem
they're replacement Theory but the idea
of replacing a population is not uh
something that's a figment of your
imagination it's intentional and it
doesn't have anything to do with race it
I mean race is a component of it I guess
just because you're talking about
changing demographics it is about a
voting base
it is about taxes it is about ensuring
the security of one party at the expense
of the American worker and of course uh
mug Club it's super chat Thursday should
be a wild in woolly one
mm-hmm have you watched Scrooge yet this
year not yet I'm going to though we got
one that's Wild and Woolly yep my dad
and I have used that term forever and no
one else I love that big black lady in
that film she did she appeared a lot in
80s and 90s films she did until all of a
sudden
so uh look let me ask you this are you
looking to uh join Mud Club here in the
new year and um if you're a current
member have you entered in your email at
mugclubforever.com if you entered it in
yesterday please please re-enter it in
there was a problem the servers crashed
again because we went with the strongest
biggest servers I said oh no this should
handle it I said are you sure you're
gonna
and they said yes we are and it crashed
immediately yeah and special thanks by
the way to Jeremy of the quartering he
stepped in and helped us last night all
night literally all night he's not it's
not a sponsor to the show I will tell
you though we all use coffee brand
coffee here it's great I actually prefer
some of their teas in the coffee but
just look the guy stepped in is a saint
yeah and uh and uh he he refuses to
charge me anything which is uh is he a
wine guy I'll send him some wine I don't
know I'm sure he's a drunk
all kinds of straight from my
understanding uh oh no Jeremy from
recording yeah I know he is yes no he is
he really is yeah I think you're
thinking of someone else yeah he's okay
but I just don't think he wants wine
Gerald oh oh here's the thing I thought
you were thinking of another person yes
and I thought you were implying another
person was straight of course meaning
they're not right I was like no this
isn't him but then I realized it was a
wine joke yes yeah it was a time a
little bit stressed no no it's fine I
think it's the cortisol effect it was it
was just a knock it's because Gerald
says that he's gay all the time no he
doesn't every day
just every day I
I thought Gerald hey how are you I
I'm great
how are you and his stocking was hung by
the chimney with [ __ ] look at that there
it is
I started going to bat for you I came in
I said why didn't hey hold on a second I
know you guys don't give me this stuff
but why doesn't Dave have a stocking oh
why his stocking thank you guys but he
didn't know he would we should have not
said because he's colorblind oh that's
true
totally heterosexual stocking and
there's a light shining on it so it
makes it even harder does it really it
really does I looked back and almost
didn't realize it show Lewis see the
same thing yes no pretty much but he can
kill all of it I can't yes all right uh
so let's move on to the show as usual
look we're about to show you a clip and
I want you to play along at home
and guess what happens next it's like a
choose your own crappy path book all
right let's start it
you see what's happening here
okay so what do you think happens next
is it either a
that's a lot
both parties come to their senses to
resolve the situation peacefully and by
the way there's no sense as it just says
sense but this was done last minute uh
B either way it's not a so who cares
wait hold on a second let's get to the
phone I realize I didn't introduce I'm
going to introduce you but we have to
finish this then I'll introduce you yeah
you're good B
the officer checks his privilege and
they both go on their merry way that's
good that would be seasonal or c
this
[Laughter]
what's all over the ground to shoot a
pinata
did you see when she fell the first time
the pole Falls
[Laughter]
no yeah
oh so I'm not now
I think the woman is just fine or this
is just you know you know mess around
with cops and don't follow uh follow
orders and uh you could taste yeah look
look there are a lot of bad cops out
there are too quick to reach to their to
their belt absolutely yeah exactly I
don't need like you know I'm just being
pulled over for a speeding ticket I
don't need you to grab your shock
repellent but
it is one of those situations where it
was pretty clear she was given quite a
few outs let me ask you this do you guys
think as white CIS males we explained
through that yesterday sis I know it's
so confusing I've I learned a lot
yesterday
if only you could unlearn I know I I'm
still still upset about it if you could
be like in existenz where you could just
travel back before you knew it turns out
I'm a CIS yes
I'm an ovarian CIS now
um does anyone here white white CIS male
if do you would you expect anything
other than that to happen if you were to
completely disobey a police officer yeah
don't you expect it like I'd expect a
baton yes I'd expect worse yeah I guess
that's pretty bad even when I get pulled
over if they I one time I had a cop pull
and his hand just probably was in his
pocket I was like ah ten and two here's
my credit card here's my business here's
my business account information just
leave me alone I mean I don't know you
think we just walk let me just walk up
and slap cops in the face like a like a
native tribesman challenging the Bears a
test of manhood what do you think we do
I've had cops pull guns on me several
times well yeah that was warranted it
was warranted I'm not saying it wasn't
yeah but I'm saying like look if they
shine with a rubber bullet and I lived
there'd be a video people laughed at yes
it'd be the last Castle yeah
I'm just saying everybody has to like
kind of walk on eggshells like well
we're not laughing at like it's a video
online because you are yeah every human
being that we are but other horrible
people she eats eggshells yes
yummy by the Golden Corral short by the
way you know them you love him fastest
man on his feet he is going to be in
Syracuse this weekend I don't know if we
have an overlay but you guys can go and
follow him on social oh there you go
Syracuse
New Year's
in Toledo at Toledo in Toledo Ohio again
have some Skyline uh yeah yeah sure
Skyline davelandau.com and by the way
Ahoy we've talked about how I'm sorry
this is a weird day uh myclub
forever.com I don't know how much time
this is going to take their issues out
of my control uh so you can always go to
loudouncrediter.com tour I will let you
know for sure that I'll be doing some
dates January February at the very least
at the very least I will be doing that
and don't let me lose touch with you
everything else look I wish
I wish I may I wish I might but there's
always you know my hands are tied
legally tight
but you're going to be in Syracuse yes
this weekend
uh it'll be snowy so don't you have no
excuse me I'm out okay uh let's get to
trans female hot you good Jill okay
oh you got good updates yeah oh as far
as people signing up yeah is it working
is it working God the server is working
can we have a celery hey Jeremy at the
quartering we have an overlay for him
people go out and support this is the
only reason you are able to sign up is
Jeremy at the courtroom hit some kind of
celebratory music oh is that all I have
to celebrate good time or something all
I have is Gerald's stocking confetti yay
by the way you want to know where I get
it from Crawdaddy's not here but we were
listening uh with the with the twins
that we had a Christmas playlist and
then last Christmas okay and they're
just playing my my dad's bouncing
bouncing uh well as he hands him over to
my mom and he goes this is a song about
him banging the guy in Los Angeles stall
oh that's why I am who I am yeah thank
you some of us learned trades
so uh oh it is yes let's uh and thanks
so thank you so much to Jeremy do we
have an overlay for him or no no just
Jeremy I think his channel is the
quartering thank you so much it's a
really great show our servers would not
be working if not he really did he
stepped in he's actually doing on his
website thank you so much okay so this
is a funny one and by funny one I mean
confusing and I mean uh confusing to the
point that I don't fully understand it
yet it's rare that I come to you and say
I'm about to deliver a story to you and
I don't get it so it was a tournament
organized by a a transgender team is it
actually called team trans uh you know I
think it's by team Trends they're yeah
their team is team trans it's a terrible
name Oh I thought it was called blood on
the ice it's definitely descriptive well
it's hockey Dave they're gonna you know
there's Fighters fighting that's what
he's called in the 90s right yeah yeah
yeah just a different texture so uh it's
an all transgender I guess and it's it's
a it's a not anyway here's what happened
hockey team based out of Boston and uh a
a man
a biological man slammed into a
biological woman I believe there was a
concussion this is and by the way if
you've played hockey or if you don't
like obviously violence against women
which I do not I would warn you not to
watch this clip but I'm not really sure
if it qualifies because I don't know
what this story means a biological man
hockey uh checked a biological woman
this is what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
they were down for 17 minutes now here's
something I don't understand here was
that a that a uh was that a biological
man
or was it a uh uh was it a woman to man
yes woman to man yes it was woman demand
man to woman slammed into the uh woman
to man yes yep so that's a win right
yeah well no equality yeah so it's all
it's all training it's all trans here's
the problem I've said we should maybe
have a trans league for a while what I
didn't foresee
[Laughter]
you still end up with the same problem
once you add in steroids Yeah well yeah
once you toss that in there it's still
an issue there's no usada testing I
don't believe yeah uh although I'm still
for it yes I just think it's look if
this is what the game you wanted to play
I think it's it's fine yeah sure I know
I'm not I'm not again I'm not saying I'm
just saying my point is I think it's
good that it's progress I think they I
think they followed the letter of the
law but I think they missed the spirit
of the law which is biological women
shouldn't be having the crap kicked out
of them by men
yeah there should be hold on you mean
bumped come on that person was skating
on the ice and he accidentally got hit
by a larger person well there should he
or she got that person I said that
person I think I don't know you don't
even know the answer do you maybe it's
me a smaller person skates onto the ice
and gets hit by a bigger person well
that could be a Swedish person fighting
a Russian well that's it should be
women's leagues still though and a men's
league it's just the women's league will
be the trans the larger more barbaric
player you know what let's just let is
that right he's not saying whether
you're biological male to female or
female to male yeah if the league is
kind they'll take you in as one of their
own isn't that right all right I'm
watching a tribe somewhere in Minnetonka
right now so one of the spectators name
that movie line by the way Phil Hartman
saved that movie uh comment below tool
man what do you like what are you doing
bath salts a little bit
[Music]
that's why you were wearing the goalie
mask yes one of the spectators actually
I thought it was a hockey theme had this
to say
oh well come on there's no way he was in
a hockey game now can't say man you
don't know that there's a lot of
difference with that leak ma'am the
thing is with Chris Tucker I will go
back to it by the way uh meanwhile in
the Russian hockey league in case you
wondered that they thought maybe they
had an upper hand culture in the United
States uh this is what's been going on
there
[Music]
thank you
nice so they're supposed to punch a ref
yeah but so they're still playing
awesome hockey yes exactly
well I'm sorry Russians I know a lot of
people hate them but that's how hockey
should be played they really do know
their hockey here's what I don't know
what Chris Tucker is saying almost ever
I only know what Chris Tucker is saying
at the end of his phrase everything hey
oh man I got
and then I'm gonna have to stomp on you
I got the last part there you go see I
love them it's Friday and yeah and
that's that's it but it's hard for me uh
no I like that I didn't ask you to speak
Yakuza I don't I don't dislike I don't
dislike it but I still like he's amazing
in Friday yes and then when he got like
when Friday two came around it's like
well you're too good now how did this
happen because you're in rush hour okay
look here let's just move on with the
story the two players involved were Lexi
Seton and Danny Maki Mackie oh my God
can you see if you can guess which is
which
okay so the woman on the right knocked
out somebody on the left it's science
the woman on the right knocked out that
uh Lumberjack on the left knocked out in
the The Man in the pink or the blue we
could be wrong about all of this no what
I'm being serious no that's the so am I
here's the thing I did such due
diligence on the uh and everyone here on
the you know the demographic issue
on the left the one on the left knocked
out the one on the right really what
Chaz Bono got sent to Neverland oh the
one with the beard got knocked out
correct yes awesome
good for her I mean him you're sent to
the shadow realm so wow that's a good
player though one Twitter uh user
replied that like so Men playing on
women's team they don't understand but
here's the thing the NHL is really clear
on it the NHL they kind of avoided the
wokeness for a while but it's like a
sick it's like Remember The Neverending
Story the nothing yeah it hits
everything the NHL responded trans women
are women trans men are men non-binary
identity is real okay hold on mud
clubforever.com please go and enter in
your email because you know look not
only do we have a war of course against
big Tech you never know what you can say
and what you can't say and please do
head on over to rumble if you're
watching on YouTube nothing will make me
happen in the CLD subscriptions go from
YouTube to rumble I'd love to see those
numbers change uh but the reason I say
all that is because
um non-binary identity is not real it's
not a thing
it was never a thing until a year and a
half ago if you want to say transvestite
sure transsexual sure trans the
non-binary thing it can't work remember
I told you this can't work in a society
the non-binary thing can't work there
was a podcast I listened to I don't
remember how long ago this was it was
during this podcast it was a woman slash
non-binary who would switch
mid-interview to being a man or a woman
and was offended if you didn't use the
proper gender Sybil yes well that's just
confusing
how are you supposed to how are you
supposed to non-binary identity is real
well do we have non-binary can someone
fact check this do we have non-binary on
our uh on our licenses do we have
non-binary no we don't so you can't just
switch it every day let's stop trying to
act as though that's hate speech you're
gay fine no one cares but you're trans
go do your thing and you just can't
demand that everyone declares you a
woman if you are what you call a barely
passable Blair white friend of the show
it would be impossible for me to say
that guy there because Blair white you
meet you're like you would say that lady
there because Blair white clearly looks
like a lady if it's a mental Mind Trick
if it's a Jedi mind trick where you I am
a woman I'm not going along with it and
I don't even have a chip for I am
non-binary that wouldn't work it doesn't
work on anybody despite what the NHL is
saying if the NHL believes that
non-binary identity is real put women in
the NHL
there you go why is there separate
League put them in the NHL equal equal
rights baby Brittany Greiner on skates I
agree he's been in Russia a little while
I'm sure she skated she had to pick up
some other by osmosis right it's all
over the place I I I don't understand
the world anymore I don't either I don't
know I've lost the gift uh uh hit the
like button yeah you know please know
it oh forever.com
is a gift that is a gift that's always
been a gift but I've lost I've lost the
gift unless unless tool man brings the
overlay I've lost the gift
and there it is I see flashes of a gift
a gift
I hate all of you this is for people
who've been watching for the last year
and a half it makes sense to the rest of
you I apologize but I don't so here are
women and demon babies will attack you
the server they attack the servers
that's why the server was ready
forever.com and then I'll tell you the
problem in Demon baby know how to do the
keyboard
Tanya know their way around core team
dude that's right
I came in they took the letter A off my
computer and I'm like oh man nobody's
gonna know what I think the demon baby
the way you identified demon baby they
will always use caps lock they can't eat
chocolate or that's dope that's a
Telltale sign or the demon baby caps
lock so women
and I mean women
and I mean I don't know are suing Elon
Musk now so let's set this up of course
you knew this was going to happen
everyone is so litigious out there like
look if you were fired just move on your
Merry way if it's a Business Partnership
that doesn't work just just just stop
just go on with your life but former or
just steal stuff from the office like a
normal person exactly
by the way forward I I you know I know
that you stole the coffee machine
because when you invited me over for
movie night I saw it proudly displayed
on your Island it was good coffee okay
well thank you Corey what are we getting
you for Christmas gift so these former
female employees and by the way this is
really poorly worded because they're
going to say formerly female no
perhaps formerly female as well but
these are former female
umbrella female term employees at
Twitter they are now suing Elon Musk for
what they are calling discriminatory uh
layoffs 57 of women were laid off while
47 percent of men were laid off and the
statistical significance of those
numbers is through the roof this can't
be explained by the fact that musk said
that he wanted to keep more engineering
type positions because we analyzed it
based on an engineering type positions
and the disparities between women and
men were even more Stark you know it
changed overnight I've been through
other Acquisitions I've never seen
anything like this well she recovered
from the hockey we just want them to
live up to the commitments that they
made to us
and like staying with the company
through the acquisition process it's
very important for Elon Musk to realize
that he may be the richest man but he is
not above the law and the law in this
case okay hold on everyone everyone shut
up remember the rules before we come
back to the clips just let me hit first
because
do we have this pull that back up I had
I did I had no idea that Henry sahuto
worked at Twitter I never knew that come
on oh wow
and by the way you guys can clip this
and send this to Henry because I know he
has a sense of humor I'm not saying
Henry shahudo that you look like I'm
saying that this person clearly copied
your haircut and I respect the balls
that you've never changed it despite how
silly it looks
I do want to know which haircut
which haircut was left on The Cutting
Room floor when you opted for that what
was the second choice when she goes in
and goes just use the balloon yes done
is rubber over one of those static
plasma balls oh I like how you cleaned
up the sides it's a perfect flowy hair
yeah exactly uh that's a flobby for sure
that's a good call good pull and I think
we've also noticed not the epitome of
Health CNN actually has live footage
from Twitter HQ right now my grandma
Works faster than you and she's only got
one leg
[Laughter]
he's very cruel to them yes yes yeah
it's hard to be fast with one leg
Goldberg was a National Treasure he was
not the wrestler no no Goldberg from
Mighty Ducks yeah you know what else is
a National Treasure myclub forever.com
do not let us lose touch with you isn't
it wonderful to know that you'll never
get any spam you'll never get any crap
your email list will never be sold you
will just know when if and where mug
Club returns and hey Everyone likes free
stuff I don't like paying for it
um
so New York City of course you know has
had Rising uh crime rates no uh yeah and
they've had fallen recruitment numbers
with police officers and I look
Humanity's 101 uh coordination sorry no
exactly I'm just speaking in a general
term and
I'm probably lying okay New York is
doing superbly go visit it yeah you'll
see it's a great place to go yes go
visit New York you can check all the
references go for a stroll at night yes
leave your valuable somewhere we can
find them like a hotel not in a safe
yeah so uh they also uh of course you
can check the references at ladder with
crowder.com but there have been some new
crimes that have been committed which
brings us to our latest installment of
Empire State of crime
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there was a massive fire in a
Brooklyn uh evidence facility uh which
yeah there's nothing else to say just
here it is Jim Smith is live in Chopper
2 over the area right now with more Jim
and Mary yeah we could tell you that
smoke is blowing in a general South
Southwest Direction yeah just so you
know that facility held facility held
seized Vehicles property DNA evidence
from unresolved burglaries or murders
and police cars that were involved in uh
murdered officer cases so this has the
Fingerprints of the FBI all over it how
many people are watching that just like
yes I'm getting off Christmas came early
son there's a guy walking and there's
like sweetie I got another parking
ticket oh okay oh good news we'll have
to do that I'm sorry I must have been
lost on the fire people just start
punching meter maids in the face yeah I
love the Intrepid reporting as you can
see there is smoke blowing that way yeah
is that North or South well I guess you
should hire a compass for scale Susie
thank you dirty [ __ ]
we're going down go there will be more
fire soon yes losing control of the
captor yep
that's not even the weirdest crime that
has taken place of course in New York
and you know had record crime rates and
of course they've had problems with
their police look I I can do all the
fact checking but you can just go back
it's remedial we know about the the bail
the basically The Catch and Release Bail
that happens we know about the defunding
the police we know about the rhetoric
from their mayor it's no surprise that
this is happening but what is a surprise
some of the crimes the nature of them on
Wednesday uh we had a perp in New York
caught on tape robbing and here's no I
know I know what you're thinking
it's not what you're thinking so it
wasn't McDonald's but it's not the type
of you would think cash register right
this is the robbing the McDonald's in
the Bronx these are searching for a
suspect who stole food from McDonald's
in the Bronx it happened at the fast
food restaurant on East 170th Street in
the Mount Eden section last week now
investigators say the suspect you can
see him here threatened workers with a
knife before going behind that counter
uh by the way by the way we actually had
the mask but now we have an exclusive
photo of the suspect in question um we
of course
so let's be clear you think okay knocked
over McDonald's they probably have a lot
of cash on hand New York City no he used
a butter knife and stole McDonald's food
he still he was trying to stuff
cheeseburgers into his pants pockets
that's never gonna work out well before
the Biden Administration that was dollar
menu stuff yeah that really was aim
higher love the cash register
what are you doing chicken nuggets don't
fold you got some of those apple pies
those are good
I left money your Line's long I know
the one time was apprehended by the cops
they almost arrested me really it wasn't
me it was a Montreal the Metro turns
down I could hear the last sub and there
was a person on the phone who refused to
just hit the button open I'm like I put
my ticket in I put my ticket in and I
jumped and then I said
you can't jump a Turn Style I mean I
left the ticket I've done that and then
they're like I have to I have to ring
you up and I'm like I was standing there
for five minutes I'm leaving with this
and I left you extra money yeah didn't
help it I had a pocket full of fentanyl
though
so he stole two double cheeseburgers two
dozen chicken McNuggets those are good
and uh I mean you know look I guess we
talked about I think it's kind of I
don't like the fact I think it's a
little racist the new hamburger is
Hamburglar is black I agree and there's
better chance he's gonna end up in jail
and those fry kids are gonna grow up
without a father right and create
potentially more hamburglars and a lot
of pregnant teen grimaces yes uh
pregnant teen Stacey Abrams a suspend
Empire State of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they all have their own thing you know
Kanye's he's ah ah I just like that why
it's like it sounds almost like a Street
Fighter character that boy good perfect
yeah
foreign
yeah now about to do a stab I call this
one the Zagat
okay I guess if that's what you want to
do that's what you want to do it's an
award
uh my Bone Thugs had it right they just
had backup yep
nothing to mess with no brings the
Ruckus uh okay by the way we're going to
be taking your chat of course today and
we will be broadcasting Monday and
Tuesday very short on YouTube just to
let you know because we're doing you
can't say that on YouTube segments for
the end of the year all the stuff that
we can which if you watched us when we
were on Rumble a band from YouTube It's
not that different from the show except
you know if you have anything to say
about elections or if you have anything
to say about the the most let's just not
see maybe stuff like that you stop I
just said the name go stick your head in
the stocking and then put it in that
oven right there now no okay I tried uh
let me ask you this because we've talked
about this in the past they've tried to
coin this term the great replacement
Theory as though it's something entirely
uh racist and that's the term has been
used by racists sure but they try and do
we've talked about language this week
right for example woman was changed by
Cambridge the definition woman no longer
means what woman has always meant Donald
Trump it came down to he was removed
from Twitter for saying 75 million
Patriots they said that Patriots that
was coded language for terrorists
um when we're talking about this right
here hey toolman I have a question why
is your drink so far away from you you
have to reach across half a football
field show people how you have to reach
I always think he's going to put out a
fire
can we get you a cup holder okay okay
that's a good Christmas present yeah
yeah do you ever see it it's like I just
add it for my eyes see
you gotta get something cool though
Tim's techie like I got gunmetal maybe
yeah yeah that'd be nice for the side of
his desk I'll throw in on it yeah okay
all right just always I always think
there's something wrong like he's about
to hit a panic button
okay there's actually a panic is there a
panic button yes yeah I have one I just
hit it all the time it's just I'm
sitting here in half the time
I have one in case I fall yes
and can't get up oh you I got mine from
G Gordon Liddy oh nice yeah me too
in case I have a heavy hamper yeah it
comes in handy when my tub door doesn't
open correctly you've seen those
commercials for the Grandma's like on
the ground in the black and white
commercial and it's just like is this
happening just she's just dying she's
starving today
oh my gosh he goes they show me they
don't even show me the fun part like
show me the part where she falls down
the stairs breaks her hip you just show
me her already like I fell down
there's a whole thing of white people
doing stupid things in infomercials yes
it's hysterical you can't open a can
yeah like that's me though I don't have
the can opener yeah Dave does why people
are like I don't know how to put food in
a dog dish what I want to do that
they're like by the food dish here I
don't understand the concept of density
it goes through okay weird I'm white and
dumb so language speaking of white and
dumb language has been changed patriot
means terrorist woman doesn't mean woman
and if you discuss fertility rates and
if you discuss changing demographics
because of that you discuss different
voting bases the left wants to silence
you uh
by using the accusations of racism right
it's silencing you out of fear of being
accused of being a racist so we're not
talking about the term as it's been
coined and co-opted great replacement
Theory I do however want to walk you
through uh the idea that people are not
having babies that people of course and
this is not only a problem in China but
particularly in the west that we do have
a population problem and I know that the
neo-environmentalists want to tell you
that we're overpopulated on on this
planet Elon Musk has also uh dispelled
that and I did it I think in 2010 at the
Cancun climate Summit but even just
discussing your country again this is a
global right it's a global approach oh
we need fewer people on Earth but guess
what you need more people in your
country to keep the economy working so
it doesn't necessarily always have to be
this Global cabal of people peeing on
redwoods at Bohemian Grove all you need
is people approaching the world from a
mindset if Mother Earth is most
important we need fewer people and guess
what that hurts your nation because you
need a Workforce so authorities in the
UK now they've outlined a plan that
would send migrants to rural areas and
this is according to their migratory
advisory committee these are the
recommendations
we believe it is in the best interest of
the UK government it's a pilot and
evaluate a rural Visa targeted at areas
facing depopulation and that such a
pilot will align with the government's
commitment to level up all parts of the
UK
and France can suck me [ __ ]
that sounds like a great plan this place
is so bad nobody voluntarily wants to be
there but let's send the immigrants
there no one was that's because that
place is a right proper
oh jeez I mute it no I know but I still
heard it through your microphone no okay
no no just it just missed it to you
though hi
you're right proper okay I forgot I have
a mute button that's so much more fun
it's such a jovial word over there
though it's not it's not harsh like it
is oh we have a Girl by the way hi Sarah
who works for us a girl lady from uh the
UK because she's on a different time
zone so sometimes she'll send news
updates because we're asleep one time
she was on Skype and she I swear to you
20 times use the c word yeah but anyway
like oh oh sorry pardon me if you have
kids she's like oh oh Stephen how are
you chicken and I was like oh stop [ __ ]
what
up saying bastard
my friend
my friend from Ireland he said it was a
kamikuted felon and I'm like I've not
heard of Zach without the c word
it's a purpose no to them it's not it's
just how they talk this is the issue
with language and this is why the left
wants to control and change language so
this is what they're saying in the UK
right let me actually just because uh
the accent might have thrown you off
there saying that of course they are
facing depopulation and so they want to
bring in people on visas right so they
know deep they've accepted depopulation
is a problem birth rates are a problem
the way they solve it is with work visas
bringing people in from largely third
world countries by the way you don't
need to take my word for it all
references are available lighter with
crowder.com this is exactly or I should
say very similarly Echoes uh what Chuck
Schumer said just last month now more
than ever we're short of workers
uh we have a population that is not
reproducing it on its own with the same
level that it used to the only way we're
going to have a great future in America
is if we welcome and embrace immigrants
the dreamers and all of them because our
ultimate goal is to help the dreamers
but get a path to citizenship for all 11
million or however many undocumented
there are here hey how about the
ultimate goal is to uh better uh the
situation for the American people I
don't know crazy idea that'd be racist
so is any of this true the idea of
fertility the idea of you being replaced
and by you I mean by the way American
citizens white black brown white red
yellow in his sight whatever the point
is my point is you you know like I could
I'm using the Jesus loves all the
children but I think I might have gotten
some colors wrong
when why do Western leaders now that we
know they say this why do they want to
bring in so many immigrants from
countries that don't more specifically
don't share our values as a matter of
fact come from countries where if you
look at their laws are antithetical to
our values comment why you believe
that's the case below but it is
undeniable that that is the case so let
me get let me get to some of the numbers
here uh let's get to fertility rates
okay
the minimum fertility rate to replace a
population is 2.1 all right and low
fertility rates are a big problem in
most places in the western world as I
refer to it good world
including the United States our
fertility rate is 1.64 Canada is 1.5
Germany's 1.53 UK is 1.56 France is 1.8
probably a little bit of one wine
induced uh the only Western Nation above
this rate if we're using this term is
Israel at 2.9
um so we're all well below replacing the
actual Workforce replacing the actual
population that we need to sustain our
country regardless of race so when the
replacement rate of course the
population is going to start to shrink
right are you guys you guys all
following the map yes yeah so what
happens is that it's not just the
population it's not just the economy but
the culture starts to change yes right
so the cultural values and Norms of any
place I'm not just saying one good
weather bad I'm just saying period
whatever that culture is if you bring in
people from outside that have their own
culture which sometimes can be good they
can add to it but not always yeah
there's a lot of people that don't
really add much to what's going on right
now in some of these countries they
bring in that and it dilutes that
culture and by the way just to be clear
just just when you try and say it's a
race thing I would take 50 Cubans over
one Swedish socialist yeah absolutely
it's not a race thing at all I don't
want the swedes they're cowardly hockey
players yeah and I don't want Mars
Attacks nope yeah think about that no it
was Tom Jones best work agreed yes uh so
here's another fact that you guys need
to understand and we need to just we
need to look at this realistically uh
demographics overall so let's look at
the percentages of you you know American
families American families uh who have
children that is dramatically yeah
declined over time right so in the 1950s
48 of American families you know had
children but the 2010s it's been about
31 percent golly and now today the
recent most recent poll I believe it's
the most recent one of the most recent
uh 44 of adults in the United States
don't ever expect to have children
now that's a little different because it
means they don't expect to and how many
times have we heard like young women
saying I don't need children I don't I
don't want them in office under 35 like
window yeah by the way really
interesting point here when we were
looking to get a comparison of a survey
like that right we showed you the the
people with children and that number
dropped precipitously right percentage
it was so expected there's no data from
the 1950s like people are like why are
you asking me if I plan to have yes yeah
okay of course that's all well yeah it
was also yeah if you were a Catholic you
were like yes I'm going to stop I guess
whenever my body stops yes I mean I
guess the 38 I think we're gonna plan on
30. yeah the uterus will give the answer
yes
I will start at 19 of course three years
after I married yes and then to have 57
children it will probably end when I
find what's happened down there too
gross to continue right when it becomes
too easy for childbirth yes yes it looks
like I put a cherry Bob in the pet
hamster when either businessman
alcoholism stops my husband's erection
permanently yes oh my womb just says
goodbye yes they usually both tend to
intersect at the same time 44 now of
course this is also uh this is also
perpetuated because of the media who
says you don't need children to be look
that's not true most women are more
fulfilled and more happy when they have
children when they have families if you
are a woman watching right now let the
world know that you exist hit the like
button because YouTube says you do not
exist they say that every woman is a
third wave feminist I can't tell you how
many women I meet who disagree with that
and by the way women always become more
conservative they get married they're
more conservative they have children
they're way more conservative if their
children are involved with sports
way more conservative particularly if
they're a girl now in 2021 here's some
more data pure research looked into some
of the reasons that people were not
having kids now I know what you're going
to say we talked about this with divorce
80 of divorces are filed by women okay
nowadays it's actually like 90 for
couples with college degrees and I went
through these the top five reasons uh
domestic abuse is lower than before
infidelity is lower than before didn't
even make the top five it was that they
weren't happy or they felt that their
partner wasn't doing enough so I know
what you're thinking here research would
show that there are people not having
kids and we have some top reasons you
would think there's some kind of and we
are not discussing these people people
have biological issues people have
difficulty you know conceiving of course
we're not talking about and I think that
you know that but we always have to put
that disclaimer in case it gets taken
out of context you can go screw yourself
Media Matters now when you look at these
answers five percent answer they didn't
want to have kids because of the climate
hmm wow nine percent said the quote
state of the world okay why that's fair
that's a guy who doesn't want to have
kids telling you she's like really come
on don't you think I'd make a good mom
it's not you Sandra it's the state of
the world
you know what I'm glad I'm gonna go out
again with the boys tonight yes yes yes
help the state of the world improve so
we can have you're going out for the
sixth night in a row for I've already to
a state of the world that's right you
did tell me the state of the world world
yeah how come I've never met in your guy
friends I'd shut up well you just don't
understand
state of the world yes as the nine
percent of us do five percent so they
won't have kids because climate nine
percent state of the world and 56 the
climates said they just don't want to
learn so here's the Silver Lining those
don't sound like a special well of
course if it's a child they shouldn't
bear a child well yeah or he sounded
like the dinosaurs I mean they all kind
of sound like
a cat gotta be honest anybody between 18
and 40 kind of sounds like that right if
you're the head of Twitter trust and
safety exactly in the ages of eight well
yeah well yeah I just don't wanna yeah
good great well at least I have a child
yeah
I mean I know we want people to you know
have families and stuff like that but
with the people that answered I don't
know if I want them to right that's what
I mean
these don't sound like very conservative
answers which brings us to another Point
conservatives have more children
significantly so for example pro-trump
counties had a 25 higher uh percent of
uh they had a 25 higher fertility rates
properly then the pro Biden counties I
know what some people are going to say
well that's because they're dumb that's
because they're not that ivy league okay
well you know what you think if you
believe that you believe Florida was
Dumb and California did it right
okay you believe Florida did it wrong
New York did it right the myth of the
intellectual you really think it's the
intellectuals who say that what you just
saw in that hockey game
makes sense no I think that
working-class Americans and by the way
many of them have college degrees or
trades no I don't think they're I don't
think they're having children because
they're unintelligent let's just let's
use this argument for a second let's go
with it oh so they're so unintelligent
they're so uneducated that they're
having children guess what they're
happier
and they end up raising more successful
families
hey what what did your degree do for you
what did your Masters in German poetry
do for you so voting for Donald Trump
voting Republican directly correlates
with having higher fertility rates and
you know what I know I know this is a
fact we've known this for a long time
no because there's at least one
documented case that showed exactly
how that worked
how can I help you
doctor my husband and I have tried
everything to try and get pregnant do
you have any suggestions
I do have something that's worked in the
past
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
wow
thank you Doctor you're very welcome
every time
paid for by the greatest president in
the history of the world
side effects frankly may include
being fantastic
okay by the way by the way
um mugclub forever.com I I uh I I don't
want to say I lied to you I was wrong
there's way more than 300 000 of you out
there
way more and if the numbers that we're
seeing right now continue here as we you
know have to please pardon our dust
there's nothing that can ever compare to
what we can what you can accomplish what
we can all accomplish if you sign up and
you make sure to check your spam because
obviously you have Google right they're
going to be very aggressed with the
filters we might end up doing a double
opt-in which means you just have to
confirm that you want to receive from
that email uh we can bring a lot of
people in here who have been wanting to
have shows produced and want people who
have their backs there's a there's a lot
of good to come out of this and you know
what there's room for everybody so what
are we about saying these really quickly
like that that is not an automatic email
that they're going to send we're saying
if we do that double opt-in you'll see
it so don't look if you don't receive an
email immediately about that don't worry
about it right when you hit submit and
your email disappears you're good to go
baby you are good to go what we may do
in the future is make it because the way
spam filters work you'll get an
immediate email saying hey did you mean
to sign up for this email I promise
you're not getting anything from Marco
Rubio shop I still can't unsubscribe
from that [ __ ] and you don't even hate
Marco Rubio no I don't hate micro Rubio
he's been in the show it was very you
know there should be a discount do you
get emails from the Marco Rubio shop I
have and I've never even signed up
neither did I hold on can we but I have
unsigned can I get more of them I want
to see what he's got in his shop what in
the world could he possibly have small
hands mostly dick pics that's like the
opposite of a phone mascot hair
it's a nuclear baby face put on your
fingers it's a number one but it's very
tiny yes
if you visit the site they automatically
subscribe you so oh it's the Deadpool
[Laughter]
which in some cases are advantageous so
here's another Factor range reason
Democrats need immigrants and I'm not
saying need brown people need black
people need yellow people what I'm
saying is they need immigrants
specifically immigrants from third world
countries in order to ensure their
Stranglehold on power here's why that
matters that is diametrically opposed to
what is in the best interest of you the
American citizen and when I say you I'm
speaking to by the way gay William our
Cuban American agent I'm saying you to
uh Mariella a lady who works with
cleaning lady who we work with who's a
nanny who's Bolivian who's so excited to
undergo the Naturalization of I think
green card and then is actually getting
the citizenship I'm saying you mom who I
love French Canadian who came here and
loved this country dearly so bringing in
third world country immigrants to ensure
a voting base is opposed to what you of
all Stripes here in the United States
Tax paying citizens uh actually need in
order to maintain the country that that
you flock to don't take my word for it
let's LeVar Burton this crap just listen
to Democrats in a few years we're going
to be a majority Brown country white
people will not be the majority in the
country anymore this will be the first
generation ever in American history in
which whites will be a minority of the
generation at some point as of 2007.
every year babies being born in this
country whites now are the minority bad
suit and background for him everyone is
going to be a minority as the
demographics
when people become the minority in the
country which is coming demographics is
Destiny demographics is Destiny
demographics is Destiny right the
country is changing now the reason I say
that is that if you say demographics is
Destiny me or shouldn't be demographics
are Destiny I don't know demographic
demographics is let me ask you a
question is it demographics is Destiny
you ask me a question I asked you a
question
demographics are just someone can
correct us and you can admonish us I
don't know it could go either on TV for
such a lack of them yes I know
demographics so they tell you it's a
race thing why because if you then
address immigration it makes you a
racist don't fall into that trap like
I've talked about
um you know when people say there are
higher standards of living for example
I've used them to change my mind there's
some stats that just stick with you
forever uh Swedish uh citizens yes they
have a higher standard of living than
American citizens that's true but
Swedish Americans have a 50 percent
higher quality of life than swedes in
Sweden same thing for Danish Americans
so when you are taking people from a
country which is largely homogeneous and
they have a culture that values labor
that values industriousness that shares
sort of traditional more Western values
guess what you transplant them to the
United States they do better you don't
have that same issue with people who
come from third world countries who will
of course
yeah lower and some people they don't go
to jobs I get that you watched South
Park but statistically it is
economically true that the left wants
immigrants to come into this country not
in order to better the country but
because they believe that these
immigrants will do cheap labor be happy
to do it and vote for them here they are
saying we need them to do cheap labor we
have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers in the Growers saying why
are you shipping these
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
go put on your Kwanzaa scarf [ __ ] no no
I'm sorry not immigrants we're not
talking about immigrants we're talking
about people who come into the country
illegally that's the people that were
being sent up North so that you can
handle the problem that you guess is not
really happening down on the southern
border that you wanted to show you this
is real it's hard to deal with and until
you guys fix the problem we're just
going to let you see what the problem is
like how about we just talk about the
fact that she used the term shipping yes
well we're upsing though no one can talk
about that Next Day Air yeah
no you're absolutely and by the way a
big reason this is true too it's very
difficult and as we continue of course
mug Club mugclubforever.com please stand
up we you know we've been looking for an
American manufacturer for the mug yes
for years we haven't been able to find
one uh now we do have this of course
etched and painted here in the United
States we've even been looking for a
type uh Taiwan many can't find them
here's a problem it also ends up being
created by the left is they're so strong
and pro-union and I mean corrupt Union
to talk about like SEIU you're talking
about like the UAW uh to the point where
the average salary is well over 140
thousand dollars for a factory work at
UAW and include benefits time off Lasik
right so they make it unaffordable to
manufacture in the United States they're
therefore necessary to bring it or to
ship manufacturing overseas or to bring
in people on h-1 visas to say hey we
don't have Americans who can do this we
need to reduce the cost of goods and
services get rid of the corrupt unions
and let's close up our border and make
sure that we are not just bringing in
cheap labor it's it's not a difficult
solution this is one of those issues
that is not a hard solution and that's
how you know it's by Design if it seems
relatively simple and you examine it
from all angles and it still seems
simple then you have to ask yourself why
is this simple solution or really three
Simple Solutions why are they not being
implemented here's another fact that's
pretty important immigrants overall they
actually have higher fertility rates
than native born Americans so we talked
about the United States at somewhere
around 1.6
fertility rate immigrants it's over two
now what about the immigrants who Chuck
Schumer wants to Grant citizenship
according to a 2013 Pew survey
the Hispanic immigrants who were not
citizens
identified themselves 33 is independent
31 is Democrat four percent is
Republican hey if you're not a citizen
and uh we don't believe that they vote
according to the left right we have a
problem that's why we believe in voter
ID because some of us suspect they do
vote why do I give a [ __ ] how you
identify I'm not a socialist I don't
plan on being I'm not European I don't
plan on being European so who gives a
crap if they're socialists I thought
this was a really good sting operation
yeah only non-citizens can participate
in our poll and then immediately you're
driven right back across the border
right I thought that's how laws were
supposed to be enforced yes but here's a
silver lining okay this I bring you
Tidings of great joy thank you it is
Christmas yep and there and their cigars
shall be assigned on to you
spoiler right you understand okay when
it comes to immigrants and we have a
really good gay one we do there's one
exception not only one exception but
there's one that is is Cubans yeah Cuban
Americans and by the way I know what
you're saying oh it's actually the
Cubans started going to well everyone
shifted toward Barack Obama in more
recent years it's not just that Cubans
are incredibly conservative but young
Cubans are incredibly conservative far
more than young uh white Americans and
Far More by the way than even older
Hispanics and other demographics young
Cubans have rejected what they have seen
if they are here in this country that is
important now we would think right they
just said white white people are not
going to be the majority I just told you
I would take 50 Cubans over one Swede
sweet is really really white
why because Cubans come here and they
desperately want to be a part of America
they appreciate it they're hard workers
they're industrious they pay taxes I
have never met a cuban-american who
first off could make a fantastic
sandwich and it's the best I I didn't
just very much enjoy their company and I
know we'll get some of the identitarians
who get mad at me look just listen to
some of these statistics and this is
also why you see that Cubans are treated
differently from other brown people so
last year uh Biden's Homeland Security
Chief Alejandro America said this about
Cuban refugees allow me to be clear if
you take to the Sea you will not come to
the United States hey hold on a second
so we Grant Asylum to people who are
leaving places like Mexico El Salvador
Honduras and by the way
they're not seeking Asylum they're just
leaving crappy countries you know if
you're shipped back to Mexico pretty
much nothing happens right you know what
happens if you get shipped back to Cuba
it depends on the day and it depends who
catches you these people are actually
fleeing a persecutive government they
have a claim for Asylum and that's why
we had different policies regarding
Cubans for a very long time so you have
Nancy Pelosi you have Chuck Schumer you
have Majorca saying hey whites are going
to be a minority right we're going to be
a majority Brown country come on over
dreamers hey come on over we're we're
not in a country that's cruel we're a
country that's feeling hey Syrian
refugees that are all military-aged men
and entirely Islamic coming from
countries where they're burning
Christians alive even though they make
up less than one percent of the ref yeah
come on over Cubans wait not so fast
yeah was it illian Gonzalez who came
over here in the 90s do you remember he
was like a little boy I was thinking of
that
maybe I'm not speaking wrong on the net
it could be it was cousin he also was a
cousin called Slowpoke but uh but it was
a huge issue because yeah it's uh
sending him back is such a catastrophic
issue yes as opposed to sending somebody
back to Mexico and by the way I don't
know if you notice this is actually I
just talked with William about about
this the economic conditions right now
and uh communist rule combined with
covid
globalist policies right let's be honest
covet was a globalist approach
let's create the largest Exodus from
Cuba since Castro Rose to power
so yeah there's a guy named Roger Garcia
ordaz who has tried to flee Cuba 11
times there's a story out there and he
said uh of course I'm going to keep on
throwing myself into the sea until I get
to the U.S or if the sea wants to take
my life so be it so here's my question
to you why do you think I'm sorry
Slowpoke Rodriguez I just I didn't
interrupt you I was thinking Gonzales
okay okay that was his cousin we're both
children go on I just want to be called
out on this it's okay I know yeah so
avoid privilege like Gonzalez that's
right when we're discussing important
either way you put a baseball in their
hand they're going to throw it a quarter
mile now
I have a question for you why do you
think the Democrats don't want to
support that's Puerto Ricans oh my God
I'm way off Dominican oh gosh any demand
12 year old of the Dominican Republic is
better than Babe Ruth yes exactly it's
not even close so why do you think
comment below they don't want to support
Cubans Democrats okay let me uh give you
uh some pretty clear numbers here in
2022 Ron DeSantis won 68 of the Cuban
vote and by the way young Cubans meaning
ages 18 to 39. hey that's our demo they
drastically favored Republicans
Republicans uh as far as favoring
Republican candidate 61 young Cubans
favoring a Democrat candidate 27 you
don't find that kind of spread anywhere
else anywhere else you will not find
that kind of a reliable Conservative
Republican voter base anywhere else
including in the rural South so I want
to be crystal crystal clear when the
left says demographics is Destiny I'm
still not sure if it's if they're right
if it's not our destiny you're clear
oh look what's happening on CNN right
now are those oh they're not Cubans oh
they're just hey walk across here yeah
let's bring this up on scene and bring
up the volume but what is looming over
all of this John is the prospect of
title 42 being suspended next week this
is a surge different from from all of
that but the Biden Administration is
preparing for as many tonight as as many
as 9 000 to 14 000 people crossing uh
the board I sure hope you're preparing
with an upright trampoline yes daily
preparing for that number every single
day right yeah just think about that uh
where people have been sleeping and
those again see what they're saying
they're preparing for them daily that's
a little bit different from the rhetoric
Isn't it nice when we get to fact check
things on there at least rebut things on
there I should say in this case we'll be
talking about Biden's Homeland Security
uh Chief Alejandro mayorcas said about
Cubans allow me to be clear if you take
to the Sea you will not come to the
United States right now they're
preparing for all of these people we are
rolling out the welcome mat hey they're
both Brown
they're both coming from countries that
have been economically devastated I
would argue the difference is that
you're actually persecuted in Cuba since
it's a Communist Regime and you're not
allowed to speak out you actually do
have political prisoners on a regular
basis despite the fact that you know
Michael Moore actually went to Cuba and
sicko and said that they have better
health care than us
I missed him when he was fat
is he thin now I don't know he looks
like in transition Walter White ah
hahaha at the end of the series or I
don't know why no because he got really
picture any part of this okay yeah so
Cubans Cuban Americans This is hey why
don't we look at why don't we look at
changing that pal they are Furious as to
what happened in Florida by the way
Hispanics are migrating uh more and I
mean this sort of politically more and
more toward the right Cubans have always
been on the right slight exception under
Obama that's because it was the worst
candidate of all time on his left yeah
oh sorry I always forget the my right
they're left followed closely by John
McCain Romney McCain horrible candidates
the whole country went kind of toward
Obama they shifted back and Cuban
shifted back in a really really big way
and young Cubans what does that tell you
this is what that tells you
um people who have seen communism or
socialism they reject it so outright I
mean you should hear gay you know our
agent there gay William talk about it he
hates Communists along with Puerto
Ricans but that's a story for another
day it's a whole thing sometimes about
my friend though Who Came From Russia
yeah and just I mean even when you talk
about like federoff and people that got
to a store and were like I don't
understand you can buy anything right
people that stood in bread lines who
came here and were million millionaires
can you understand like I don't think a
human being can understand the concept
of the of you know having seriously
nothing right and then the chance for
pretty much anything you want right
absolutely and they're willing to take a
risk they're not just walking through an
open fan a wall that doesn't exist
they're taking they're they're I saw
actually the uh the float graveyard when
I was doing some shows for the troops in
Guantanamo Bay these makeshift rafts
these people there is some buy-in there
is some buy-in because they want to be
Americans they're not just saying Hey I
want to go be a day worker and then send
some money back to Cuba so let's kind of
recap this and again please go to
mudclub forever.com don't let us lose
touch with you
if you want to be a part of my club you
want this to continue we pardon our dust
uh it's going to take a little bit of
time here we will do right by you enter
in your email you will only receive the
email once where it is back up and
running we have to build this house have
to be the little piggy who built his
house out of brick I don't know how the
other Piggies thought a house would work
with straw when they knew that the wolf
had a pension for blowing houses down
but done it before it's a story for
another day now uh before we go we'll
take your chats we will be here Monday
Tuesday Christmas special on Wednesday
Democrats immigration while we're
talking about you being replaced okay
they don't want you meaning they the
Democratic party does not want you to
have big families why well a couple of
reasons first off if you have families
mom dad and kids guess what you are now
statistically conservative
also you are now statistically as
inoculated as you can be against going
to prison
right against poverty against divorce
against mental illness if you have Mom
and Dad and they are currently in your
life you are less likely to rely on big
government also people who have big
families guess what happens they tend to
move out of major cities where leftists
want you dependent on public
transportation they want you dependent
on the infrastructure that they have as
opposed to being autonomous and of
course Democrats want to increase their
voter base and bring in cheap labor so
they can take your jobs just not Cubans
just not Cubans common if that seems
like it's a little bit of a shell game
hey how about everyone out there says
Cubans over swedes how about that let's
see let's see if that gets struck as
racism Cubans over swedes comment that
below and see what YouTube does I would
take a million Cuban refugees and actual
refugees over a single Finnish socialist
by the way Finland is boring as hell and
at least the Cubans have I mean there's
a lot of fun they're a fun people they
got cigars he had a Cuban sandwich
there's nothing like a red Cuban coffee
a little too much sugar but it's
unbelievable and we are going to
continue being happy warriors joyously
with well it's the it's the Christmas
season in our hearts we will see you
Monday and Tuesday thank you again so
much to Jeremy at the quartering please
let everyone you know and if you signed
up yesterday or the day before just do
it again the servers have been fixed
because of Jeremy I cannot thank him
enough mug Club
forever.com oh yeah that's not
necessarily the most flattering mug shot
but it might be hard to come by sorry
Jeremy you have inner beauty
myclub forever.com YouTube right now
piss off
[Music]